hello everybody today i'll be talking
about our work interactive communication
in battlefield 3
it's trying to work with gmo and green
autopilot levy from google
we mainly consider the battle trade game
where we have sally the seller and bob
the buyer
sally has a private cost for an item
theta is drawn from the distribution bs
and bob is interested in buying the item
and he has a private value to the b
drive from a distribution bb
the distributions dn bs and db are
public information
and
are known to both players
and in the end sally will choose her
action
by choosing a press p
and then bob upon seeing the press will
accept if his private value letter b is
greater than or equal to the price p
and if there's no trade then both player
will get zero utility
and if there is a trade then steady will
get utility of p minus or cos theta s
and bob will get the utility of
theta b minus p
so we can depict the situation in the
following figure
in the case where that s is less than
delta b
we can
[Music]
write down the price on this number axis
so if the price is less than the cost or
if the price is higher than the value
then there won't be a trade because one
of the players are going to be willing
to take the trip
and if p
lies between theta s and theta b
then there can be a trade
and in that case bob wants the price to
be lower and steady want the price to be
higher and we know that the sum of the
utilities is a fixed number which is
value minus cost
and in that case the
trade is efficient
but the the players want to push the
prices
into different directions
so in this metaphor trend setting
from the revelation principle we can say
that interaction is not useful
and we might as well just use a direct
mechanism
and from the medicine centers with serum
we know that
we can't design mechanisms that always
allocate whenever the treat is possible
so we can't always get the efficient
solution in this game
however in reality
there are a lot of bargaining processes
going on
for example car dealers and real estate
agents
have jobs based on
bargaining
and our goal of this work is to
design a model of balanced retreat that
captures the power of this interactive
communication
so for this purpose we will introduce a
new ingredient
which is the usual persuasion model
in this model there is a receiver at the
center the sender knows some state of
the world data joined from a
distribution b
and in the end the reservoir will take
some action a from some action set a
and then
the receiver will get
a utility of us data a
depending on the state and correction
and also the sender will get utility up
depending on the state and action as
well
so in the basic transmission model the
sender can choose to send some
verifiable signal sigma correlated with
the state
to update the receiver's perception of
the state of the model
and then
upon receiving the signal the receiver
can
choose her action to maximize
her expected utility
condition of receiving the signal signal
and there's a famous special case of the
asian persuasion setting
introduced by bergman brooks and maurice
and this setup is for selling an item so
study is trying to sell one item to bob
and sally always has a fixed cost for an
item
but bob has a variable value for the
item drawing from a distribution d
and in the end sally will
choose a price p for the item and then
bob will accept if his private value is
greater than or equal to p
and if there's a trade then steady gets
the utility of p minus or cost and bob
gets the utility of his value minus p
and sally will choose her price p to
maximize her expected profit which is p
minus theta s times
the probability of there is a trade
and in this model we let bob send some
signal beforehand depending on his
private value on item
and then sally will get the signal
and then she will choose to press p to
maximize this conditional expectation
so she will maximize the price minus our
cost times the probability of applying
the item given the signal
and the result of the paper of bergman
brooks and maurice can be summarized in
the following sentence so bob has a way
to send the signal
so that the trade will be efficient and
bob will be the one to capture the
remaining surplus function
and we generalize their model in the
following way
so now steady no longer has a fixed cost
but has hard costs joined from some
distribution bs as well
and in that case we can
view
the model in the following perspective
so in the beginning sally has some
perception db
on bob's private value
and bob has some perception bs of is
permit cost
and then bob can send some signal sigma
to update stanley's perception
and suddenly
when
she receives the signal she will update
her perception about bob's private value
into this db prime
and then she will set the price p
depending on bb prime and her permit
cost and we can further generalize this
model into
the so-called variation conversation
in which there are multiple rounds of
sending signals
so
you can say in the first round study
since some signal sigma prime
depending on her cost
to about
and then bob will update her perception
of sally's
private cost into this distribution bs
prime
and then in the second round bob can
send some signal back to setting about
his private value
so sally will then update her perception
into db prime
and then finally sally can set the price
depending on dd prime and her private
cost
and we can further generalize the
conversation into having many rounds and
in the end sally will send some press p
so now we formally introduce our model
of interactive communication
so in the base theme
there are two agents steady and bulb
they have tab spaces data s and data b
and their types are drawn from
independent independent distributions
dsmdb
a study has an action from the set eis
and then the final payoffs are the
functions us and ub depending on the
types
your data sm therapy and also sell its
final action ais
also the communication is an
international protocol where bob sends
messages to in outruns and studies and
specifics in even rounds so for example
in the second to last round
um sally sent something to bob and then
in the federal office something back to
study
so a message from bob to sally is a
refinement of status information about
bob
so
in the message from bob
it can depend on
bob's information about steady and also
sends information about bob
and then it will output the distribution
of status information in the next round
as a refinement of status information
and we
require biggest plausibility in the
model
so we require the posterior
to be equal to the prior
and similarly we can define a message
from selling to bob
and that should be a refinement of bob's
information about study and still be
required based plausibility
and we can define the payoffs as
communication in the following way
so that's high i t dsdb
be the utility for player i in the t run
particle and the perceived distributions
are bs and bb
so for an odd t
it's the term for bob to send the
message so that should be
expected on
pi i to the t minus 1 bsdb prime where
db prime is updated by
bob's message in the rom
and for unt we can define it similarly
that's the term for steady to send her
message
and she will update
bob's perceived distribution to the ice
plane
and we take the expectation over pi i to
the t minus 1 the s prime d
and for the equilibrium concept we
adopt a concept similar to the sap
imperfect mesh equilibrium
where the agent's choose messages to
maximize their payoffs
and in our work we assume the receiver
can always choose to refuse to hear any
message
and also tags are broken favorably to
the other player
and now we can define a concept called
message complexity
so we notice that in equilibrium agents
will always quickly improve their
payoffs with more runs
so for any agent i pi i to the t plus
one is always greater than or equal to
pi to the t
and that is because for the message
cylinder in each rung
he or she can just choose to send
nothing to the other player
to guarantee the same payoff as in
the setting where there's one fuel run
and for the receiver because of our
assumption that the receiver can always
choose to
to refuse to get the signal we know that
the utility is always monotone as well
for the receiver
and that
allows us to take the limit of the
payouts because the sequence pi i to the
t is monotonically increasing
so we can define the limit pi i to the
infinity
as the limit payouts
and finally we can define the message
complexity in the following way so it's
just the smallest number t so that pi i
t equals the limit payoffs for each
agent
and then totally that just means
having more runs than t will not help
anyone in the setting
and our main result can be summarized in
the following sentence
agents won't stop communicating until
they reach an efficient application
mathematically we are saying that
if we have a finite message complexity
then the final allocation will be
efficient
so uh
the limit payoff for selling plus the
limit payout for bob
will be equal to the maximum
efficiency we can get from this trade
and our main result leaves the following
question open
and we summarize it
as a conjecture
so we can just sure that the message
complexity is actually always finite for
any distributions with valence support
in this palette setting
and if this is true then we know that
interactive communication
always ends in finite rounds
and it's always leading to efficiency
and also
if this is false then we know there are
settings where agents would prefer to
have an infinitely long conversation
before making a trade
in our paper we also have the following
result
if bob's tab space has support size of
two
then we can fully characterize the
communication structure of that game
and in that case the message complexity
is always items too
and now we briefly introduce our proof
techniques
so for our results that fannit message
complexity leads to efficiency
we can use the following recursive
argument
so for the base case where message
connectivity is zero we can easily show
that the allocation must be efficient
and then we use the recursive argument
that if there's a protocol of a finite
message complexity t
then we can construct another protocol
of message complexity t minus one
also leading to individual outcome
and therefore
by this recursive argument we can show
there can't be any
protocol of finite message complexity
into individual outcome
and for our other results of fully
characterizing the case where bob has a
simple size of two
um we
characterize the dynamics of alternative
concavification
and that can be viewed as a higher order
version of the indifference argument
in the work of berkman books and marvels
and in the end we want to introduce
another game called spy game as an
example of complicated and
non-communication
so in this game we have studied the
stepmaster and bob the birth voucher
and their types are drawn from zero and
left
and we can view that as two separate
countries countries around the country
and in the end studies actions are to
cooperate with bob or to expose bob
and the payoff matrix is like this
if they are from the same country then
study what to cooperate
and if they
are from different countries there is
like a 0-7 game and sally wants to
expose bob
and initially we assume bs and db are
almost half so
they have equal probability to from both
countries independently
and
we implement some experiments in this
game and it shows that
in equilibrium the communication
protocol is quite long and involves
gradual disclosure of information
and we conclude our talk by
repeating our main message because long
interactive communication can improve
outcomes
and can often lead to efficiency
thanks for listening